so yesterday I explained to you that
while Donald Trump was complaining that
the Federal Reserve didn't give him the
big federal funds rate cut that he
wanted he was deliberately ignoring that
from August first on his additional
tariffs on China have really been
hurting the stock market and yesterday
when we were producing the show I said
as of right now the stock market the Dow
is down nearly 600 points and it ended
down more than 700 points the worst day
in 2019 so far and the reason is Donald
Trump's trade war which includes now
China devaluing its currency which I'll
talk about momentarily and it is getting
worse and worse this is going to be
terrible for Americans of all kinds
there are all sorts of moralistic
arguments we can make about China and
their behavior but in the end this is
bad for Americans now the Dow is down
nearly 6% just this month it's August
6th mind you through August 5th
which we had two weekend trading days or
rather two weekend days that were not
trading days down nearly 6% the Dow back
down roughly to where it was in January
of 2018 which is nineteen months ago S&P
500 down about three percent yesterday
Nasdaq down even more 3.5% so this is
bad and it's bad even for people who
don't necessarily own lots of shares of
stock as I've described before and you
know what China is going to keep messing
with Donald Trump now that Donald Trump
has declared trade war war on China a
type of war nevertheless China has now
allowed the yuan their currency to
weaken beyond seven yon per dollar for
the first time in ten years and Donald
Trump is attacking them on Twitter
saying quote China dropped the price of
their currency to an almost a historic
low it's called currency manipulation
are you listening Federal Reserve this
is a major violation which will greatly
weaken China
over time really get the feeling that
Trump has China on the ropes right like
any second China's going to relent and
come to the table and give Donald Trump
everything he wants yeah obviously not
and it's important to understand
this currency manipulation allegation
which is not untrue by the way China
does manipulate the value of their
currency for trade benefit purposes by
reducing the value of their currency it
makes it cheaper for other countries to
buy stuff from China to import to their
countries if you get more yuan per
dollar you can now get more Chinese
stuff per dollar effectively making it
cheaper that's true and it's not going
to change the way that Donald Trump has
been handling Chinese trade policy it's
having the predicted effect which is
that it's crashing out our stock markets
and in more bad news for the United
States China has asked state-owned
companies to just stop buying
agricultural imports from the United
States altogether so if you thought that
American farmers had been getting
crushed for the last nine months and
they have been as I've told you about
that has been nothing compared to what
you are about to see upcoming this isn't
sustainable but more importantly Trump
doesn't even understand how this stuff
works Trump's policy to the extent you
can call it policy is driven by
misunderstandings about the most
fundamental elements of trade and
economics and currency combined with
this attitude that he has of everything
being a win-lose negotiation and who's
the strongest and who's going to come
out on top
Trump so-called business experience
which was the reason that many people
voted for the guy to begin with
his business experience we were told
would translate really well to being
president and we knew that that was a
joke anyone who had any common sense
knew that was a joke Trump's business
experience is daddy gave you money to
get started everyone around you was
constantly brown-nosing and you just
ignored all the - all the rules all the
time while bossing people around things
are different now yes Trump what hasn't
changed this Trump is still surrounded
himself with the brown-nosing sycophants
that's the same as when Trump was in
business but Trump has tried taking the
same sort of attitude with China and
China is not you know some concrete or
steel company that Trump has over a
barrel
the
is not looking good period no matter
your political affiliation and that's
what I hope people understand it doesn't
matter whether you're for or against
abortion this is bad bad bad there's no
sign of it getting better particularly
when the president sees it all as sport
wins and losses without even
understanding what the definition of
winning actually is it's going to get
even worse unfortunately today's program
brought to you in part by Blink accom
slash Pakman Linkous is a great service
that i use all the time what they do is
they take thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber
which I listened to on blinka they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you'd like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month that's be li NK
is t.com /p a que mas